I'm here hello everyone and welcome to
today's live broadcast fecal lactoferrin
measurements in clinical practice
presented by dr. Paul Ruffo an assistant
professor of pediatrics at Harvard
Medical School and program director hms
fellowship in pediatric gastroenterology
at Boston Children's Hospital
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes laborat is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual event and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on that screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on that help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use that ask a question box
and let us know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process for obtaining your
credits I'd now like to introduce our
presenter dr. Paul Ruffo
dr. Ruffo is an assistant professor of
pediatrics at Harvard Medical School and
the program director of Harvard Medical
School fellowship in pediatric
gastroenterology and hepatology at
Boston Children's Hospital he's a senior
associate in the center for inflammatory
bowel at Boston Children's Hospital and
is affiliated with Beth Israel Deaconess
Medical Center and Brigham and Women's
Hospital his research is focused on the
development of new modalities for use in
the diagnosis and interval assessment of
children and adults with IBD his
research also involved the development
of new therapies for
inflammatory bowel disease as well as
Quality Assurance initiates in this
patient population
dr. Ruffo received his medical degree
from the University of Massachusetts
Medical School and an MSD degree from
Harvard Medical School please join me
now in welcoming our presenter dr. Paul
Ruffo welcome sir good afternoon
everybody and I'm delighted to have this
opportunity to talk about lactoferrin
and biomarkers this is an area that I
have had a long-standing interest myself
and others have had a long-standing
interest and I hope over the course of
the next hour I can impart on you some
of my enthusiasm for why I think
lactoferrin and other biomarkers are
important and will become increasingly
important as we move forward in this
this age of limited medical resources
and I hope to give you an idea
practically of how one can think about
using lactoferrin measurements in
clinical practice and I do welcome
questions I'll run through the slides
which should take about 45 to 50 minutes
and I'm going to budget about 10 to 15
minutes at the end for questions so I
hope everybody feels free to write down
their questions and then and then we'll
run through them as we move forward so
I'll just say that in terms of
disclosure you've heard a lot of
different things I have been working
with tech lab for some number of years
I'm a speaker for AbbVie and a
consultant for loopholed and Shire and
that's what I have to disclose as I said
earlier we're going to review a little
bit about biomarkers in general like
lactoferrin and why they're important
and maybe think about them in a way that
you haven't thought about them in the
past and then think about how we can
actually use them they're a great tool
but like any great tool the quest
how can you use it it's a it's a good
hammer or a good screwdriver but it's as
only as good as the application you you
use it for so I want to give you some
practical practical information about
how one can use this sort of technology
in in day-to-day dull longitudinal
management of patients and then we'll
finish with some future directions where
biomarker and especially lactoferrin
research may take us and and once ago
write those questions down as I move
from slide to slide the first few slides
are going to be much more in general and
we're just going to talk about
biomarkers and this is how I got
involved in the science in the first
place
we as gastroenterologists are constantly
tasked with the the job of figuring out
how our patients are doing either what
they have or what they how they're
responding to our therapies and and
biomarkers help us and especially
important because you can use them in
place we collect them with respect to
blood or radiologic or exam efforts and
we we come up with an endpoint a
measurement and we use these biomarkers
when we can't get the information we
want in a different way sometimes it's
very difficult to get a particular bit
of data due to the need for invasive
evaluation sometimes it's prohibitive
because of patient discomfort a cost
well sometimes it's just impractical
because it would require extended
periods of observation and we're always
tasked by this how how can we tell our
patients how we're doing when what
they're doing especially with respect to
IBD is something that happens on the
inside of their bodies so we we can't
really readily do endoscopy and
colonoscopies on these patients all the
time so the question was how can
we assess this otherwise and that's
really how I fell into the biomarker
literature in the latter part of the
1990s in an effort to sort of figure out
how I could better assess treatment
response and at the time I was using a
new therapy and was trying to figure out
how I could assess the efficacy of a new
therapy without having to rely on serial
invasive studies biomarkers are
important to clinicians like us because
they can help us make an initial
diagnosis they can help us take a
patient who walks in off the street we
can get a history we can think about
what sort of diseases we have and if we
have the rice assay if we have the right
biomarker it will give us a good idea as
to whether or not our patient may have
or may not have something and both both
aspects are important the ability to be
able to say that someone does have
something or doesn't have something
biomarkers are also ideally positioned
for longitudinal data so we initially
want to figure out how our patients or
what our patients have this is the the
patient that walks in off the street
with with diary or a bloody stool and
we're trying to figure out whether or
not it's more or less likely that they
have IBD that's a one-shot deal then we
give them our diagnosis we follow them
for the next 20 or 30 years depending on
if we're pediatric or adult castra
neurologists we need to have a way of
assessing their response over time and
one thing that's very good about
biomarkers is that they provide
objective data with continuous
measurements and lactoferrin is going to
fit all of these criteria as we draw
this together and ideal biomarkers can
help us predict relapse they allow a
component of proactive management most
of the or at least much of the
management
do nowadays is reactive we see a patient
comes to clinic they report a set of
symptoms that may be different from the
last clinic visit and we make a change
in their management based on that
wouldn't it be nice if we could figure
out which patients were at risk for
flaring and we could modify their
therapy before they had clinical
symptoms so ideally biomarkers are going
to help clinicians with respect to
proactive management and then a separate
set of biomarkers may actually help us
define clinical phenotypes we may be
able to use biomarkers lactoferrin and
others to figure out which patients are
most likely to respond to to individual
therapies or we might be able to figure
out which patients under what
circumstances are most at risk for
particular complications so the the
wheelbarrow of information that may be
imparted to us by biomarkers is pretty
broad Pharma has been one of the primary
driving forces for biomarkers in all
disease pathways not just GI
cardiovascular hypertension diabetes the
whole thing and biomarkers are very
important to Pharma because they help
shorten the duration of a study if you
have to assess the response of a drug or
an intervention on a patient population
the last thing you want to have to do is
wait two years five years ten years if
you're thinking about a medication that
might affect heart disease a heart
attack the last thing you want to do is
want to wait twenty years or thirty
years to see who develops heart attacks
instead what you want is a biomarker in
in heart disease literature I suppose
they use cholesterol and statin statins
the efficacy of statins are imparted by
by how they impact on
cholesterol measurements by shortening
the duration of the study they lower the
cost of the study they reduce morbidity
subjects are going to be less likely to
have to undergo invasive testing or stay
on a study for a longer period of time
and hopefully improve accrual so the
studies that you see in your journals
whether they be the pediatric journals
or the New England Journal they're going
to look at biomarkers and you're going
to see them reported as outcome
variables precisely for this reason
because investigators not just in Big
Pharma but investigators are going to be
leveraging these biomarkers to provide
Expedia information to their readers and
hopefully change clinical care in the
short run biomarkers are also important
to researchers everybody is a researcher
to my view and I tell that to the
fellows in our program all the time
we're all interested in taking existing
information and using it in the best way
for the next patient and researchers can
be people who spend time trying to do
big studies or write manuscripts
researchers in the broadest sense can
also be people who are who are looking
to adapt technology and when you when
you broaden the definition of researcher
to include that population of people
we're all researchers and I provided
here sort of a pathway that I think is
relevant for thinking about things like
IBD but probably more generic with
respect to just about any disease
process there is some sort of stimuli
from the environment and Gi it may be a
bacteria or a bacterial product or some
microbiome that we don't fully
understand and that stimuli is imposed
on patients who have some genetic
vulnerability and that for reasons that
aren't fully clear initiate an
inflammatory cascade that will
eventually
bring patients to our office somewhere
along the line our patients with
inflammatory bowel disease whether the L
should have colitis or Crohn's disease
experience something in the environment
we still don't know but we do know that
they have a genetic vulnerability people
a whole lot smarter than myself we're
trying to figure out what those genetic
vulnerabilities are and how they can be
mitigated with respect to drug therapy
and then for years all of us have been
trying to manage inflammatory cascades
in our patients in a way that we get a
better clinical outcome you can see
these green arrows pointing in every
different direction basically every step
in the ladder gives us an opportunity to
develop a biomarker or a readout it
could be in the blood it could be in the
urine it could be in the stool that's
mostly what we're going to talk about
today and it could be in the saliva so
there's a left-to-right flow and we can
intervene on any different way to sort
of figure out what might be going on and
how that can be leveraged to help the
next patient if we understand the
patients that we're seeing today in
treating today we might have a better
handle on how to treat or at least think
about the patients that are going to be
scheduled to see us in clinic in a month
or six months biomarkers are going to be
true and and useful in all dimensions
the the last dimension along which
biomarkers are going to express the
utility's
has to do with overall health care now
we all know that we live in a society
that has expanding medical knowledge
we're very good at making technologies
that cost lots of money we have a
limited budget and the challenge to the
healthcare system in the biggest sense
or to healthcare providers like you and
me and the smallest sense is to answer
the question how can I provide the best
quality of care for the least amount of
money it's easy to provide high quality
care for lots of money
I think we can all figure out ways to do
that the question and the challenge and
the calls to task at this point is how
can we provide as good if not better
care to the patients that we're seeing
today for less money and that's where
biomarkers come in and this sort of
loops back to what we talked about in
the first slide in how biomarkers can
replace invasive studies so we have
within our power with the biomarkers
that we have available to screen our
patients to have an earlier diagnosis
maybe decrease that lag time because we
have ways of assessing patients in a way
that's palatable and cost-effective we
hopefully will develop more ways or
improved ways of disease monitoring if
we can practice proactive medicine we'll
save money if we can optimize therapy if
we can take the drugs that we're using
now and use them in the most efficacious
manner we'll save money and the nice
thing about that is those drugs are
already out there they're already FDA
approved or at least in widespread use
so if we can just if we can just squeeze
the most delicate C out of them we can
we can save money if we can prognosis if
we can take patients and risk stratify
and figure out which patients were most
likely to respond to individual
therapies or which patients were more
likely to develop certain complications
then we can save money and if we can say
do less in the way of invasive testing
we can certainly save money keeping
people out of the operating room of the
procedure suite where we spend probably
the most money in our field certainly
makes makes a difference and certainly
improves the bottom line so I think for
lots of different reasons it makes sense
to think about import incorporating
biomarkers more and more into the way we
think
about treating our patients what are the
challenges I've outlined in the last few
slides a lot of different reasons why
biomarkers are useful and why I spend my
time studying them and why I spend my
time telling you that you too may enjoy
the benefits so to speak of biomarkers
in your own practice but there are some
challenges in that remember that with
biomarkers you have to have an endpoint
that you're testing against so
biomarkers must have a valid validated
endpoint we all have to agree on what
we're measuring to see if biomarkers
whether it be lactoferrin or another
marker meets the endpoint so if we're
talking about endoscopic outcome then we
have to agree on that if we're talking
about a histologic outcome we have to
agree on that and as I say in the slide
there has to be some sort of gold
standard right now I don't think we have
a gold standard in gie we know that
patients who feel well our clinical
success we know that patients who have
mucosal healing tend to do better if you
if you perform a diagnostic or a
surveillance endoscopy on someone and
you see less in the way of mucosal
disease the likelihood that that patient
will stay in remission over time is
better than if you do a diagnostic
endoscopy and see more disease if you
take a patient that same patient and one
of them has histologic or deep remission
then that patient is even more likely to
stay in remission so depending upon
where you set your mark is going to
depend upon where your ask you are at
what level your asking your your
biomarker to perform there are a number
of advantages to using the fecal
biomarkers that we're going to talk
about today in the past the first thing
we did when people came to our offices
and had GI symptoms was stuck a needle
in their arm and measured sed rate CRP
and albumin
used those data points to determine how
sick our patients work because that's
what we had but we all know that
nowadays that sed rate and CFP aren't
very specific and that they don't impart
information entirely in line with GI
disease and could be reflective of any
disease process or any inflammatory
process or infectious process when you
use speaker biomarkers you're getting
values or proteins that are reflective
of the underlying GI disease so changes
in fecal markers should reflect changes
in the underlying GI physiology our
fecal biomarkers provide continuous
measurements with replacing subjective
measurements with I think he is doing
better or I think she hasn't responded
to now numbers we're saying their number
has fallen now what that fall in the
number means is something that we can
talk about and we can say whether or not
they're responsive to therapy sometimes
you see a patient in clinic and the
parent feels like they're doing well or
the parent feels like the kid is not
doing well and you have your own ideas
you only see the kid 15 minutes every 4
months and the question is how can you
really arbitrate this how can you how
can you take what is otherwise a
philosophic discussion about how well a
kid is doing and put it on a more
objective objective platform and
biomarkers are enable us to do that as
we move forward the hope is is that we
develop more easily used biomarkers so
maybe biomarkers that people can do at
home and that's in the works and under
development with with different
companies you can find out that you are
pregnant for about nine dollars with a
kit that you buy at CVS or some other
pharmacy with no prescription and no
doctor involved to find out if you have
all sort of kaleidos in this country
costs about ten to fifteen thousand
dollars when you add the cost of all the
testing so our hope is that over time we
can come up with fecal biomarkers that
are going to move the cause
more in the direction of cheaper more
easily easily obtained samples
disadvantage is it requires our patients
to collect stool studies stool with them
they either provided in the office or
they bring it in from home that's
requiring a little bit of a culture
change now I must say that since we
published up for a study a while back
that patients have become more
desensitized towards collecting cereal
or infrequent stool samples from home
they do it when they provide their
infectious workup and now they're more
inclined to provide it to look at
biomarker samples and I will have
patients ask me for time to time if they
can bring or send in a sample for a
lactoferrin measurement one of the
disadvantages is that
lactoferrin can be done or is typically
done at local or regional labs and it's
a send out which means that you don't
get the data nearly as quickly under
those set of circumstances as you do
point of care testing for quantitative
sorry for qualitative lactoferrin is
available and that's not very hard to
incorporate and you can talk to your own
labs about doing that that's just going
to be a dichotomous plus/minus there is
lactoferrin there isn't lactoferrin
quantitative lactoferrin can be done
in-house and isn't very difficult here
at Children's we do in-house
quantitative lactoferrin management or
lactoferrin level so we get them within
24 hours they run the assay three or
four times a week so it doesn't take
very very long and you can use that that
data and b2b management so where you
want to use or how you want to loot use
lactoferrin you can sort out with your
local lab a lab provider and see how
expediently they can provide either
qualitative or quantitative
lactoferrin or biomarker assessments
let's talk I spent about 15 minutes 20
minutes talking about biomarkers in
general let's talk about lactoferrin
specifically it is
found in neutrophils it's abundant it is
evolutionarily selected it provides a
useful measure it sequester Zion
lactoferrin it promotes optimization of
pathogenic bacteria it's quantifiable
it's very stable at room temperature
even for days but don't tell your
patients that they'll say they'll save
their stool specimens for days before
they bring it in but it is it is stable
for days and it's measured both in a
quantitative and a qualitative way most
assays are standardized and the cost
isn't tremendous one hundred two hundred
dollars maybe even less so it's readily
available and not terribly expensive and
certainly a whole lot better than the
screen for fecal leukocytes that we use
to use so I thought it might be useful
to present the rest of the talk in terms
of some clinical scenarios that we might
be able to relate to and what I'm hoping
for is that you hear these stories and
it prompts you to think of instances in
your own practice where you think
lactoferrin may have been useful or
might have been useful or mislead you in
which case we can clarify where things
went amiss so a12 these are all made-up
stories of course a 12 year old boy
presents with diarrhea and weight loss
first time you see them in the clinic
referred from a pediatrician you're
concerned about the possibility of a
chronic inflammatory process maybe the
first question you ask yourself or maybe
the primary care doctor who who saw the
patient before you and is a little bit
more proactive and prospective wonders
can lactoferrin help determine whether
or not patients are more or less likely
to have an infectious or inflammatory
processes that patient who has diarrhea
are they more likely to have Salmonella
Shigella or Campylobacter are they more
likely which would maybe require an
antibiotic therapy are they more likely
to have IBD which is going to require a
whole host of therapy or is that patient
presenting with diarrhea will
likely to have lactose intolerance or a
viral process
well the question is the the answer to
this question is yes
lactoferrin is ideally positioned to see
if people have a infectious or
inflammatory processes and here's data
from a study that was actually done in
China and what they did is they took
patients who are hospitalized for
diarrheal illness
this was unbiased they looked at all
patients and they wanted to see whether
or not lactoferrin would help bin
patients and as you can see in this
slide it's very apparent that patients
who have viral illness like rotavirus
and norovirus non inflammatory processes
more likely to have lower lactoferrin
levels and and oftentimes 7.5 is used as
a cut-off patients who have in
inflammatory / infectious diarrhea
things like Salmonella and Campylobacter
much more likely to have higher
lactoferrin measurements healthy control
patients low levels at or around the
levels seen in patients who have
norovirus disease or another viral
disease I think I didn't put the numbers
in is about 40 patients with rota
represented here 28 patients with Noro
31 with Salmonella and 17 with with
Campylobacter so you can see that the
bidding thing is fair now what you don't
see is lactoferrin discriminating what
kind of influence process or
inflammatory process is afoot and and
while these not in why these viral
values would certainly differ from the
bacterial values the there's no
statistical difference between patients
presenting with salmonella Campylobacter
and that's a weakness of most of the
available markers they do reflect GI
disease but they don't differentiate
excuse me what type of GI disease if you
look at adult patients in a similar type
of study this was done I believe in
Australia I'm going to try to draw
datasets from populations around the
world both adults and kids to show that
there's a generalizable phenomenon here
you can see that using a cup of 7.5
milligrams per milliliter or a gram of
stool or dropping that to 1.25 you can
see that there's increasing sensitivity
and specificity your ability to discern
who has an inflammatory process and more
importantly discern who doesn't have an
inflammatory diarrhoea prop process
increases considerably and that's
important that's going to be important
in terms of who you may want to treat
either based on an empiric course or
based on anticipated studies or how you
might want to talk to patients about
what the prognosis is in the likelihood
of shorter long-term morbidity would be
this is a different demonstration of
data and we can see here that if you
look at lactoferrin levels in patients
drawn from different populations it's
very apparent that not only patients who
have inflammatory or infectious diarrhea
patients who have inflammatory diarrhoea
like all sort of colitis or crohn's
disease have much higher
lactoferrin levels than patients who
have IBS I used to refer to IBS as non
inflammatory GI disease I don't think
you can anymore because I think there's
so much question as to whether or not
there's some subclinical mucosal
inflammation that's mediating some of
IBS so I just say it's IBS and I'm not
even sure you can say it's a functional
process anymore but what you can say is
that lactoferrin levels certainly
discriminate patients
with inflammatory bowel disease from
healthy controls and patients who have
IBS which is relevant especially when
you're seeing patients in a first-time
and you're thinking about making that
diagnosis that initial diagnosis risk
stratifying decide who would best
benefit from more invasive testing we
know from studies that we've done here
at Children's this was a study that we
participated here at Children's it was
also done in conjunction with groups at
the Mayo in the University of Chicago
and sort of just repeats the information
that you already saw it's very apparent
that when you look at all Commerce
patients with IBD are more likely to
have elevated lactoferrin levels than
patients who have either IBS or control
so two different studies two different
populations but very very similar
results
another assay that's out there is
calprotectin and you may in fact have
some questions about calprotectin
there's a lot of literature on
calprotectin maybe even a bit more
literature on calprotectin lactoferrin
bus the the phenomenon that they measure
is very similar both values both
calprotectin and lactoferrin are
proteins that are found in neutrophils
they come from the same cell type and
they're both used as metrics for
figuring out where white cells are where
there are white cells there is
lactoferrin where there is white cells
where there are white cells there is
calprotectin and both values are very
useful at are both sensitive and
specific for identifying patients with
both ulcerative colitis and crohn's
disease and specifically discerning
those two patient populations from those
with IBS so you can see that and they do
so in a more sensitive and more specific
manner than the existing biochemical
biomarkers or serologic biomarkers like
CRP so you get more information about a
patient's GI disease if you know the
lactoferrin Kalp
TEKT and then you do if you have a CRP
on hand so I think that's important to
remember that you get much more
information from lactoferrin and
calprotectin especially more specific
information then you can expect to guess
from CRP and said race
lactoferrin levels are relevant in both
large or small bowel disease people say
well if I have a patient who has
primarily small bowel Crohn's disease
can I still use lactoferrin can I still
anticipates the lactoferrin is going to
be useful in how I evaluate this patient
and I think you can see the data here
from a poster that we presented at ddw
last year demonstrates that yeah
lactoferrin is is very effective at both
small or large bowel oil Agia small
bowel disease and does so in a manner
that's more effective and more sensitive
and more specific probably than
serologic assays like CRP in white-cell
measurements so once again looking at
the stool is going to be much more
prognostic much more useful much more
relevant than looking at the blood let's
talk about clinical scenario - that same
12 year old boy who in the interim has
been diagnosed with ulcerative colitis
I'm not going to show you his colon I'm
just going to tell you that he was
diagnosed with pancreatic he comes to
the office and and he says he's doing
grace he has no problems but you have
your doubts
twelve-year-old kids don't always tell
us what they're feeling they are smart
enough and clever enough that they know
that if they say they feel poorly that
you're inclined to do more testing at
very least blood work and stool work at
very most follow-up endoscopy and
colonoscopy so we we conditioned them
very thoroughly to let them know that
that they're supposed to tell us that
they're feeling fine the question is how
do you deal with this and can fecal
biomarkers once you've made that
diagnosis and you have identified that
population of patients
all sort of colitis can fecal biomarkers
like lactoferrin go on and help us to
determine if there's been a change in
disease activity can we say using fecal
biomarkers that patients are sicker or
better if you want to use simplistic
terms and the answer is yes
once again useful in this particular
case not only the presence or absence of
lactoferrin but the levels will impart
information about disease severity and
remember I talked to you initially about
lactoferrin infectious colitis in this
population this is another slide from
that article looking at those
hospitalized patients there is a there
are measures of disease activity metrics
for disease activity and kids presenting
with viral illness one of them is the
ves Akari not something that I typically
use but there is for clinical trials out
there in a metric called the ves Akari
which sounds like something from Star
Wars I just say in passing but there is
a way of assessing patients admitted for
diarrhea and bend them into mild
moderate and severe disease and you can
see here in this figure that it's very
apparent that lactoferrin levels
correlate or bin
according to disease activity patients
who are sicker patients who by Vesak re
have had longer and more severe diarrhea
patients who may have a temperature or
diarrhea dehydration these are the
different parameters that are included
in that metric patients who are sicker
have higher
lactoferrin levels so you can use the
lactoferrin levels in the infected
patient patients with to figure out how
sick they are maybe think about how you
should tier or gauge their therapy if
you look at patients with IBD we'll go
from the infectious to the inflammatory
model here you have patients who have
active and inactive IBD this is
determined by I believe we use physician
global assessment this will
a study that we did in Kansai we
provided pediatric patients this is a
nice cross-section there are adult
patients from the Mayo and from the
University of Chicago this is a
cross-sectional study and you can see
that if you take a population of
patients who have active you see their
lactoferrin levels are much higher than
patients who have inactive you see and
that's true for Crohn's disease as well
so you see that over time
lactoferrin is dynamic it will go up
when people are sicker it will go down
when people Olo when they're responding
to therapy so if you see a patient in
clinic who is feeling well and has a
normal active Ferren level and then you
see them 3 months 4 months 6 months
later and you have a question about
whether or not they feel as well as they
say they feel get that lactoferrin level
and see if there's a change and you may
get different information from that
lactoferrin than you got from the
patient and probably more productive
more useful more prognostic information
from that lactoferrin than you'll get
from a CRP or a sed rate this was a
different study that we did in our
population here at Children's just kids
and what it does is it shows as you move
from left to right that lactoferrin
levels are responsive to change so if
you take a population of patients who
have active disease not on steroids they
have the highest lactoferrin levels if
you treat them with steroids and they're
feeling better and they're completing
that long taper that we all prescribed
the elective parents fall and if they
eventually become inactive and are off
steroids altogether they'll have the
lowest lactoferrin levels and you can
see those that's true for both Crohn's
disease and all sort of colitis and we
have the control population there so
lactoferrin does correlate with disease
activity both in the context of
infectious and inflammatory diarrheal
disease and one can anticipate changes
in lactoferrin as indicative of response
or lack of response given the data that
we have in front
of us right now if you look at patients
who have small bowel disease activity
once again also very useful if you look
at Crohn's s as an adult population
Crohn's disease activity index as a way
of assigning either mild moderate or
severe disease activity you can see that
lactoferrin levels correlate fairly
nicely with where P where patients are
going to be patients with severe disease
tend to have much higher lactoferrin
levels than patients who have mild
disease and even more so those in
remission so once again lactoferrin
showing it's dynamic value it's it's
ability to change over time in response
to disease activity in response to
therapy so given as symptoms our
patients with uses that twelve-year-old
patient may be a little bit older given
the symptoms our patient with you see
returns to his office on steroid therapy
as parents want to know if steroids are
working and don't necessarily trust
their son's response this is another
example of of showing the dynamic nature
of lactoferrin and the question is does
fecal Michael is like lactoferrin do
they correlate with what we might see it
endoscopy and the answer is it looks
like yes but the this is really a
million /semi billion dollar question
because this is goes to the heart of the
matter and asks the question can you
confidently use bio markers like
lactoferrin or calprotectin to keep you
out of the operating room in patients
who have active disease it's less a
question for patients at diagnosis where
the sensitivity and specificity really
do subselect out patients who are
unlikely to have a significant
inflammatory or infectious processes
these are patients who have disease well
it seems like at least in this study
which was done in adults that disease
activity was reflected in lactoferrin
levels and those who had active kalanick
disease certainly had the highest level
those who had ileal colonic disease
these are patients who have Crohn's
disease active disease patients tend to
have much higher lactoferrin levels than
patients with inactive disease in green
I used to have all the buys in red but
it was hard to project so I changed the
bias to yellow I kept the tops red if if
the slide is is puzzling you but the
bottom line is is that patients who have
more active disease and escapo
have more or elevated lactoferrin levels
our next scenario the parents of our
patients with UC probably older now than
twelve planning on taking an extended
vacation to Europe I certainly wish I
could do that with my kids but they are
planning on a trip to Europe and he
feels well but they're anxious they're
going to spend a lot of money and doing
a lot of traveling and they're going to
be far away from you who have been
taking care of their son for a lo these
many years and the concern that he will
flare and there's a question of can
fetal biomarkers predict who will remain
in remission and who will flare can you
take a lactoferrin measurement at any
given time point especially in a patient
who feels well and use that information
to predict whether or not that patient
is more or less likely to get into
trouble over the course of the next one
or several months and there is no great
prospective data but I can share with
you some information that suggests that
this may be the case if you look at
adult patients who have normal Mayo
scores at endoscopy these are patients
who come in for surveillance and dose
Coupee and they have a normal male score
and collect a lactoferrin level and then
follow them over the course of
next several months the question is is
that patient who has a normal Mayo score
likely to remain in remission these data
would drawn from a hundred and sixty
patients who are incomplete
endoscopic remission and they provided
samples and then we'll follow it over a
12-month period if you looked at the
elective Ferren levels at the time of
their procedure around the time of the
procedure those who had more elevated
lactoferrin levels in the context of
normal endoscopic appearance or near
normal endoscopic appearance when what
much more likely to relapse so yes I
think a person who has a more normal
lactoferrin level is less likely to
flare than a patient who has a more
elevated lactoferrin level sort of
looping back to what we said earlier
patients who have normal mucosa a less
likely to flare than those who have
abnormal mucosa patients who have normal
histology less likely to flare than
those who have abnormal histology so
lactoferrin and other fecal biomarkers
may be a way maybe a vehicle that we can
offer our patient some reassurance or
prognosis if you look at patients at any
given time point and you measure they
lacked affarin level all-comers these
are patients who will well measure a
single lactoferrin level and see where
they fall the arbitrary cutoff from this
study was 145 and this is the
kaplan-meier curve and what you see is
that those who have elevated
calprotectin sorry elevated lactoferrin
levels over time much less likely to
remain in remission not a surprise but
the important thing to remember is that
these patients at baseline were
clinically and distinguishable the only
thing that really differentiated them
was their cat lactoferrin level so
following people who have
elevated lactoferrin levels overtime is
likely to lead you down the path of
flair so this is one way that you can
provide some prop may be able to provide
some prognostic information to that
family interested in going to
Disneyworld or London or Paris to try to
figure out exactly where they are
perhaps if they have an elevated
lactoferrin level you have to come up
with a plan I think you have to come up
with a plan for all your patients but
maybe that patient with elevated
lactoferrin travels with some steroids
or travels with antibiotics or in this
day and age with the the GI bulletin
boards and other ways of keeping in
touch that you connect people up with
other providers in different locations
who may be available to help if your
patient gets into trouble if you look at
patients with Crohn's disease that have
undergone ileocecal resection and then
go back as is the case now we typically
go back within four to six two to nine
or twelve months and reassess that
anastomotic site and assign them what is
the route good school which is pretty
this the standardized metric for
assessing the the health or disease
activity of the anastomosis you can see
that patients who have histologic
remission low rut gut scores and that's
going to be an eyes Iiro and eye one
much lower much lower scores I should
step back and say that if you look at
people who have no disease recurrence
people who have relatively low Rutgers
scores and Routledge codes can be
interpreted as either the standard score
or modified more easily assess score
patients with no disease recurrence no
endoscopic disease recurrence had much
lower lactoferrin levels than those who
had significantly elevated recurrence
meaning lots more mucosal disease
evident this is a endoscopic assessment
histologic assessment so patients who
have higher rook at school as patients
who have larger deeper more
circumferential ulcers around the
anastomosis I'm much more likely to have
elevated lactoferrin levels can you say
that you could use lactoferrin instead
of endoscopic studies for screening
these patients I'm not sure that we're
really there just yet but certainly a
different dimension along which you can
collect very important prognostic
information and perhaps serial
measurements in the same patients over
time are going to provide you with the
most useful information and then
clinical scenario five our patient who
was 12 is now 18 is heading off to
college he is less responsive to
steroids has to start infliximab and
wants to know whether the implicit is
working can we use fecal markers to
monitor response to therapy now remember
I told you earlier that lactoferrin
levels do change in response to therapy
especially steroids it looks like that's
the case for biologics as well and this
is an area of active investigation for
both lactoferrin
and calprotectin if you look this is a
small population these are five patients
who started Remicade therapy they had
lactoferrin levels checked at baseline
prior to when they started therapy and
then further down after their first
infusion I think at the beginning of
this second infusion or third infusion
and what you can see is that those
patients had a nice response to therapy
they felt better and they had a pretty
significant drop in their calprotectin
levels so that this may be a way of
discerning who is more or less likely to
respond to any particular therapy
whether it be Remicade or
our humor Oh Sims er one of the newer
ones like in tibia or stellaris Oh
lactoferrin is going to play its role in
discerning disease activity in all these
patients and if we're trying to use
expensive therapy we have to have a way
of knowing that the expensive therapy is
doing what it's supposed to be doing and
disc op ik study is certainly in is
certainly an option but not a readily
accessible option and certainly not an
acceptable option if you ask your
patients if they're interested in doing
a clean-out and undergoing anesthesia or
at least heavy sedation hey my
colleagues who who are always interested
in using lactoferrin and know about my
passion often ask me are there other
diseases and conditions that can present
with changes in lactoferrin levels is it
100% sensitive at 100% specific no test
is and there are other conditions
lactoferrin can have low-grade
elevations in any of these parameters
now I'm not certainly not going to read
these to you but I'm just going to tell
you that you can get low positives these
are typically less than 50 low positive
lactoferrin levels with some infections
some malignancies mercifully not many
that we have to deal with in pediatrics
probably more relevant in adults
nonsteroidals responses and then a
variety of other disorders that can give
you low-grade lactoferrin levels what do
I do with these low-grade lactoferrin
levels in these patients i rechecked
them I see the patient clinic I get the
workup including lactoferrin and
infectious studies I might do some blood
work if they're feeling better overall I
might check that low level again in a
month or two months or three months if
it's per if the patient is persistently
symptomatic and the lactoferrin remains
elevated I'll bait low that's probably a
kid I'm going to scratch my head and
think a little bit about in terms of
whether or not I want to commit them to
an invasive procedure if the lactoferrin
normalizes and the patient looks well
that's probably a patient I'm going to
do a whole
a lot less - so knowing the level
knowing the level in the same patient
over time is probably going to help
guide your therapy quite a bit when
you're using fecal biomarkers like
lactoferrin so I want to leave you with
some take-home points we've talked a
bunch
lactoferrin is a great biomarker to help
sort out which patients that walk into
your office or seen in the emergency
room have inflammatory or infectious
processes
lactoferrin is likely to be useful in
longitudinal assessment of patients who
have inflammatory bowel disease what
we're doing is following the same
patients or patient populations over
time
and they're going to help us discern
who's active and who's inactive and
who's responding and who isn't
responding but we need much more
research to determine how biomarkers can
be leveraged to predict disease costs
and response to therapy and when therapy
is especially useful or futile and where
fecal biomarkers fall in as surrogate
markers for mucosal disease in clinical
trials or in clinical practice and we
just need more data more specific data
about when we can use this particular
tool in a particular clinical
circumstance and that's where I'm going
to stop I do have some time we have
about five or ten minutes that we can
answer some questions if anybody scents
them in thank you so much dr. Ruffo for
that informative presentation we will
now start that live to any portion of
the webinar and if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
drop down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started and
take our first question from our live
audience our first question
voa's are there any patient populations
that work better with lactoferrin Buuren
then calprotectin what cut-offs do you
use for lactoferrin do the cut-offs
change for different patient populations
to add to that I typically use
calprotectin calprotectin why should I
use
lactoferrin excellent so
lactoferrin and calprotectin are both
proteins found in immune cells like
neutrophils so it's very hard to imagine
a scenario in which a neutrophil would
do its business or a neutrophil would
burst and do its business and not
release both lactoferrin and
calprotectin I think in studies that
have been done the correlation between
the two levels is going to be about the
same
is there a population of patients for
which one metric is more useful for the
other I don't think that there is I
think because neutrophils and
neutrophils and they release lactoferrin
in calprotectin at the same time I'm not
so sure that disease processes are going
to select particular patient populations
cut-offs though cut-offs is really
important because the sensitivity and
specificity of an assay is going to be
depend on the cutoff as you draw as you
rise up your cutoff you're going to
increase your sensitivity but you're
going to lose some of your specificity
initial studies for lactoferrin looked
at levels of about 7 I think more of the
commercial lactoferrin levels now are
about 20 if it's 20 and below
I think it's negative I think if it's 20
and above it's positive I think it's a
low positive until it's between 20 and
50 to 80 I think once you get into
triple digits 100 you know you're
talking higher lactoferrin levels and
you can track it up into the into the
thousands so there is a 3 log range at
least for full active Ferren
measurements
and depending upon what disease process
you're looking for and this has been
especially utilized in calprotectin will
determine if you want to capture
different patient populations for
instance in patients that you're
thinking about neck or necrotizing
enterocolitis in Pediatrics because
there's a large signal-to-noise ratio
you need to use a much higher
calprotectin level to discern who is
more or less likely to have neck now you
can't use lactoferrin in this particular
patient population because lactoferrin
is found in considerable amounts of
breast milk so calprotectin is probably
the the marketer use uniquely in this
patient population
Nanga dr. Ruffo our next question is we
often encounter moderately elevated
speaker lactoferrin results with kelp
protecting levels that are well within
the normal limit and vice versa could
you provide some clinical scenarios
where these findings could be expected
so I if I think that that I here the
question is you have some low positives
and the question is what to do with a
low positive or intermediate positives
and what I do with those patients is
certainly I put them in clinical context
and that means what was the patient's
lactoferrin or calprotectin level when
they were very sick maybe at
presentation and what were the patient's
calprotectin or lactoferrin levels were
when you last saw them and they were
feeling great in clinic and that may
give you your two endpoints your two
point calibration and you can figure out
where they fit along those curves
patients who are closer to baseline may
have a small sub clinical or quasi
subclinical increase in disease activity
that's being reflected in calprotectin
or it could be that you have a patient
who has IBD and all sort of colitis and
a little bit of norovirus on top of that
patients with IBD get the same diseases
that other people get - I think the
important thing is going to be to put it
in clinical context and repeat the study
especially if you're not going to have
an intervention at a particular time
just repeat the stool sample in a week
or two or three and see if that's going
to help you decide if it's going to be a
change in in therapy
thank you dr. Ruffo and thank you to our
live audience and I just want to remind
them that any questions not answered
today during our live participation will
be answered via email our next question
is do you see the benefit of offering
fecal lactoferrin in conjunction with
fecal calprotectin as part of a profile
yeah so
lactoferrin and calprotectin provide
complimentary information and I don't
think that we're limited to using either
agents for some reasons that we don't
fully understand changes in a patient's
disease activity may be more reflective
of changes in lactoferrin or changes in
calprotectin so you may find as we
understand these these values better in
these technologies better that it may be
that certain levels ring better for
certain patients now we know that
patients we get sed rates and CRPS on
patients they both reflect changes in
disease acuity but we know that some
people are more likely to manifest
changes in this CRP before or in
response to therapy more than sed rate
as gastrin ologist do we typically get
sed rates and CRPS absolutely as gastrin
ologist could we consider getting
lactoferrin and calprotectin absolutely
in the few studies that I've seen that
have it done when you measure both
samples and you use them in combination
either in an additive or multiplicative
sed rate I'm sorry lactoferrin times
calprotectin or some component when you
add the two together the the stretch the
difference between the bars gets even
larger so if you measure if a person has
an abnormal active air in the in
calprotectin that group of patients is
going to be much more discriminated with
respect to inflammatory infectious
versus non inflammatory infectious than
those who have lower levels so using
conjunction that act probably
very useful but I think you have to
tailor it to the individual patients
just like we sort of think about sed
rates and CRPS are some patients with
IBD who who i mostly rely on this erp or
i mostly rely on this sed rate just
depends on on what their phenotype is
thank you dr. Ruth have time for one
more question what level of lactoferrin
or calprotectin would trigger you to
initiate more aggressive therapy as
opposed to watch and wait now that's a
great question so once again I think
you're going to have to view the two
point calibration that I hope you
establish with all your patients meaning
what is there what is the offical
biomarker level when they're well and
what is it when they have sick often
times around diagnosis that gives you
two point calibration in general for
calprotectin I think levels in patients
who have established IBD levels below
150 are may raise your eyebrows once you
get above 150 you're going to start
thinking about whether or not you want
to make a change I think for lactoferrin
probably lower I think once you get in
the 20 to 50 range they're in the right
clinical scenario you're going to
scratch your head a little bit more when
once you get much about 50 and certainly
once you get much above 100 that's when
you're going to start thinking that
there's been a significant change in
clinical status
thank you dr. Ruffo and would you like
to provide the audience members with any
final closing remarks before we close
today I challenge everybody to use more
of these very cost effective procedures
sparing assays in their own clinical
practice and see how they can be used to
provide patients with reassurance and
prognostic information and I think that
you'll find that the more you use them
the more you'll come to rely on them
wonderful thank you very
much dr. Ruffo for your presentation and
your important research I'd also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
and thanks for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye